[موسيقى]
عام مضى على حرب غيرت العالم في مثل هذا
اليوم من العام الماضي حانت ساعه الصفر
لاحدى اكبر الازمات في العصر الحديث فيما
بدا كشراره لحرب عالميه ثالثه امام معسكر
غربي قادته واشنطن لردع قوات الدب الروسيه
ودعم لم ينقطع منذ اليوم الاول لرئيس
اوكرانيا وقواته بالاسلحه والاموال
والعتاد في ظل اصرار قيصر الكرملين على
حسم ما قد بداه رغم خسائره المتفاقمه عام
مضى انتشر فيه مراسلوا العربيه على كل
الجبهات ونقلوا لكم الصوره بكل جوانبها في
تغطيه متواصله بدات قبل اطلاق الرصاصه
الاولى واستمرت معكم بكل ملفاتها من
السياسه الى ميادين الحرب وليس انتهاء بما
تركته من اثار على الاقتصاد العالمي على
سلاسل الامداد التي ما ان بدات بالتعافي
من جائحه كورونا حتى ظهرت الحرب التي غيرت
العالم تغطيه مستمره فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
من الصعب احصاء الاماكن التي تركز فيها
القسم
[موسيقى]
يدعوننا للدخول داخل الملجا
ان نتوجه معهم الى مكان امن
هو ليس اتفاق في الشارع وينه الطلاب على
محطات الوقود
تعاطف كبير مع اللاجئين الاخرى
[موسيقى]
رائحه الحرير
هذا مثلا صفاره الانذار اليوم كل ما خرجنا
من وسط العاصمه يزيد حده الاصوات
[موسيقى]
50 مترا بثمانيه والكمال تفصلنا عن مصنع
ازوكستان نحن الان في الطريق الى مدينه
ماريوبل
طبعا من يشاهد هذا المنظر يعتقد انه حريق
لهذه البنايات ولكن اللي كميه الاستهداف
[موسيقى]
ارسلت بولندا اليوم الدفعه الاولى من
دبابات ليوبار 2 من اصل اربعه عشره دبابه
كانت قد وعدت بها اوكرانيا واعلن رئيس
الوزراء البولندي متى
عن ارسال الشحنه الاولى خلال زيارته الى
كيف تزامنا مع ذكرى بدء العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا وكانت بريطانيا
والنرويج وسلوفاكيا والولايات المتحده
وفرنسا اعلنت تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات في
حربها
في المقابل اعلن وزير الدفاع البريطاني
بان والاس ان بلاده لن تقوم بتزويد
اوكرانيا بمقاتلات تايفون في المستقبل
القريب واضاف واليس ان امداد الطائرات
المقاتله سيتطلب ارسال مئات الاشخاص بينهم
مهندسون وطيارون مشيرا الى ان الغرب لن
يرسل قوات الى اوكرانيا بهذا الحجم لكن
يمكن ان ترسل بريطانيا 200 شخص من سلاح
الجو الملكي في وقت اخر ولكن ليس في هذه
المرحله
من جهتها قالت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
اورسو لافوندرلين ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
سيواصل فرض العقوبات على روسيا لتمكين
اوكرانيا من الانتصار في الحرب
سوف نستمر في فرض العقوبات على روسيا سوف
نستمر في ملاحقه اتباع بوت وهؤلاء الذين
يساعدون الروسيا لتجنب العقوبات او لتعزيز
ترسانتها العسكريه سوف نستمر في تقديم
الدعم المالي لاوكرانيا 67 مليار دولار
خصصناها حتى الان ثانيا مع زياده الدعم
العسكري لاوكرانيا نهدف الى تدريب 30 الف
جندي اوكراني في الاتحاد الاوروبي سوف
نقوم بعمليه شراء مشتركه لايصال معدات
العسكريه الطارئه الى اوكرانيا
شدد وزير الماليه الالماني كريستيان
ليندنور على ان بلاده لن يكون لديها عمل
مع روسيا في الوقت الراهن ولا في المستقبل
ايضا طالما ان الحرب في اوكرانيا مستمره
لا يمكن ان يكون هناك عمل كالمعتاد مع
روسيا ولن يكون هناك عمل معها في المستقبل
طالما الحرب الروسيه الوحشيه مستمره على
اوكرانيا
كيف تعيش اهم العواصم المعنيه ساعات
الذكرى الاولى لهذه الحرب شبكت مراسلينا
المنتشره حول العالم منها معنى الان منسك
مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد من كياف
مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل من واشنطن مراسل
العربيه حسين
العربيه طلال الحاج اهلا بكم جميعا وابدا
مع حذيفه عادل من كياف وكيف تعيش كياف
المعنيه الاولى بما يحصل هذه الساعات من
الذكرى الاولى على وقع تسلمها الشحنه
الاولى من ليوبار 2 كدبابات وعدت بها وعلى
وقع جلسه مجلس الامن الدائره والخطه
الصينيه
تحياتي طاهر لك ولي الزملاء يعني اولا
هنالك احتفال كبير بوصول دبابات الى
الاراضي الاوكرانيه من قبل بولندا التي
سلمت بالفعل اربع دبابات للجانب الاوكراني
واتباعا تاتي في الايام القليله الماضيه
بقيه الدبابات الموعوده بها وكذلك يصل في
الايام القليله القادمه الدفعات الاولى من
المتدربين سوى كان على الدبابات او من
سلاح الطيران الاوكراني او الدفاع الجوي
وغيرهم وغيرهم من الجنود الذين يتدربون
الان في الولايات المتحده وغيرها من الدول
الصديقه لاوكرانيا اذا سمحت لي سريعا
ساشير الى المؤتمر الصحفي الذي يجري الان
مع الرئيس والذي تناول فيه من اهم الاشياء
يعني الذي التي تناولها وقال انه اذا
التزم الشركاء بالوعود التي وعدونا اياها
سوف يكون هذا العام عام النصر وايضا قال
اننا ارتكبنا خطا بعدم التوجه ويعني حشد
الدعم الدبلوماسي من افريقيا ومن بعض
واكتفينا بالدول الصديقه والشركه وهذا
الامر الذي ستعالجه اوكرانيا كيف عاشت كما
سالتني طاهر كيف هذه الفتره العصيبه يعني
يومين كانت
الاوكرانيين كانوا في قلق وتوتر وترقب
والجميع كان يعتقد ان هذا اليوم سيكون يوم
ساخن جدا سيكون هنالك اجتياح من الجميع
الاتجاهات خاصه انه كانت هنالك انباء من
القياده الشماليه انه هنالك تحركات للقوات
البيلاروسيه والقوات الروسيه على الحدود
كان هنالك انباعا ان هنالك جحافل من الجد
يرتدون الزي الاوكراني الزي العسكري
الاوكراني سوف يقومون بعمليات استفزاز في
الحدود كذلك هنالك بعض الوحدات الصاروخيه
للقوات البيلاروسيه تحركت وتقدمت نحو
الحدود ايضا طبعا عمليه القصف المترقبه
كانت ولكن لم يحدث كل ذلك اليوم مره بهدوء
شديد ولكن يمكنني ان اقول ان معظم سكان
كيف خرجوا منك الى الضواحي وعندما تحدثنا
وسالنا الناس هم يقولون انهم يعتقدون ان
ذلك سيكون اامن اذا ما حدثت عمليه استهداف
واسعه تمام وتصريحات جديده للخارجيه
الروسيه تتحدث فيها عن الخطه الصينيه
وتقول هذه المعلومات الجديده عن الخارجيه
الروسيه بانها تقدر خطه سلام الصين مع انه
البعض لا يعتبرها خطه سلام كامله ومن عندك
حذيفه عادل في كييف انتقل الى عبد الجواد
الرشد من منسك ليعطينا وجهتي النظر
والواقعين البيلاروسي والروسي فيما يتعلق
بساعات الذكرى الاولى التي تمر عليها هذه
الحرب على وقع طرح خطه السلام الصينيه ان
صاحب التعبير
مرحبا طاهر لك والي الزملاء نعم بالفعل
يعني حتى هذه اللحظه ما زالت موسكو تتحدث
عن انها تقوم بدراسه هذا العرض الصيني
وهذه الخطه وترى فيها ايجابيه لموضوع هذا
ما تحدثت عنه خارجيه موسكو ومتحدث عنه
خلال اليومين الماضيين طبعا طاهر لعل ابرز
التصريحات بما يخص قضيه تزويد اوكرانيا
بالدبابات الالمانيه طبعا خرج السفير
الروسي لدى بريطانيا اليوم وتحدث بان هذه
الدبابات ستكون هدف يعني الصواريخ او
القذائف الروسيه ايضا ادمتري من تحدث
بلهجه قاسيه صباح اليوم وقال بان موسكو
ستقوم بابعاد حدود الخطر عن اراضيها حتى
لو يعني كانت الكلفه الوصول لحدود بولندا
لذلك طبعا هو تصعيد كبير كما تراه موسكو
بما يخص قضيه تبادل او تزويد اوكرانيا
الغربي الثقيل يرده طبعا
وتصريحات الروسيه بتصعيد الموقف طبعا لذلك
طاهر خطه المبادره الصينيه التي تم طرحها
قبل ايام يعني ترى فيها بعض الشخصيات
السياسيه الثقيله في روسيا وفي بيلاروسيا
خطه موضوعيه قد توصل يعني الازمه الى
النقاط يمكن الحوار من خلالها لكن حتى هذه
اللحظه ما زالت موسكو تدرس هذه الخطه
وتتحدث عن انه يجري العمل على هذا صحيح
طبعا ولكن بالتزامن مع بعض التصريحات على
جانب الاخر يبدو منفتح بعض الشيء على مثل
هذه الخطه هو يقول الان بانه الصين بدات
تتحدث عن اوكرانيا وهذا ليس سيئا بما ان
البيان الصيني في المقترح يحترم سيادتنا
اضافه الى قوله بانه يعني اذا كان هناك
بعض النقاط التي يمكن العمل عليها فالمه
لا نعمل عليها اي في الخطه الصينيه ومن
عندك عبد الجواد في انتقل الى واشنطن
وحسين الطاوود لاعرف منه كيف هي الرؤيه
الامريكيه مقابل ما يقوله زيلينسكي الان
لانه كان في الكثير من الانتقادات الغربيه
لهذه الخطه
تحيه لك طاهر ولجميع الزملاء الامريكيون
كما يعلنون هم مع اوكرانيا حتى النهايه
حتى النصر ومهما تطلب الامر من خلال
العقوبات وعلى روسيا ومن خلال المساعدات
لاوكرانيا طبعا الحل الدبلوماسيه دائما
مرحب بها لدى الامريكيين ولكن يجب ان تكون
حلول موضوعيه وحلول حقيقيه يمكن تطبيقها
على الارض اذا ما ثبت ان الخطه الصينيه
تتجه في هذا الاتجاه ولكن حتى الان ما
سمعناه وما رايناه من المواقف الامريكيه
هنا في الداخل الامريكي هي تقديم المزيد
من الدعم هناك مطالب الان خاصه في مجلس
الشيوخ من الجمهوريين تحديدا بتقديم
مساعدات اكثر فتاكه للجيش الاوكراني
ليواجه الهجوم الروسي المحتمل والغزو
الروسي منها حتى تزويد الجيش الاوكراني
بطائرات مقاتله طبعا هذا الامر لم يبث فيه
الاداء المسؤولين الامريكيين الرسميين في
البيت الابيض اجاك سالب تحدث سابقا وقال
الطائرات ونسي وطائرات ابسط عشر هي ليست
للمعارك القصيره للمعارك الطويله والدفاع
عن اوكرانيا على المدى البعيد ولكن ما
زلنا بحسب البيانات التي صدرت اليوم والتي
اطلعنا على عدد منها من قبل العديد من
السياسيين الامريكيين هناك وقوف اذا جانب
اوكرانيا دعم لا مؤتناهي لاوكرانيا حتى
تنتصر بحربها وطرد الروس من اراضيها تمام
ومهم جدا في هذه الاونه مع طرح الخطه
الصينيه وانتقال الحرب الى عامها الثاني
دور مجلس الامن والامم المتحده ولهذا نلجا
الى طلال حاج مراسلنا من هناك ليطلعنا على
اخر مجريات الجلسه المعنيه بهذا الموضوع
في هذه الساعات وكذلك ما يمكن ان يرتقب من
مجلس الامن على هذا الصعيد طلال
تحيه لك طاهر وللزملاء بالفعل الدول
الغربيه جالس من هذا الاسبوع في الامم
المتحده مهرجان لتضامن مع اوكرانيا وشهدت
المنظمه فعاليات كثيره هذا الاسبوع
الاحياء ذكرى مرور عام كامل على دخول
القوات الروسيه للاراضي الاوكرانيه ولكن
ربما كما تفضلت كان الاجتماعان الاهم هم
اجتماع هما اجتماع ليله البارحه في جمعيه
العامه لاستصدار قرار تبنته اكثر من 60
دوله ومررت الجمعيه باغلبيه 100
وواحده 141 دوله معارضه سبع دول فقط
والاجتماع الاخر الهام بالطبع هو اجتماع
مجلس الامن الذي السائر حتى الان في في
المجلس واسمعنا وسنستمع الى خلاله الى
كلمات عديده من وزراء خارجيه وسفراء الدول
الاعضاء في المجلس ولكن ربما كانت كلمه
الصين اليوم وهي الكلمه المرتقبه ولم
يتحدث السفير او وزير الخارجيه الصيني حتى
هذه اللحظه
بسبب الاعلان المتوقع انخطط السلام
الصينيه رسميا لانهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا
طبعا تحدث في بدايه هذه الجلسه الامين
العام وذكر بانه قال قبل عام وناشد قبل
عام باسم الانسانيه اوقف الحرب مخاطبا
الرئيس بوتين ومحذرا من مغبات الحرب هذه
التي دامت الان اكثر من عام وتحدث ايضا
ديمترو كليبه وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
وحتى على استمرار
الجهود
وايجاد حل لهذه الحرب بناء على القرار
الذي صدر من مجلس من الجمعيات العامه وهم
راضون عنه جدا ووصفته وسفيره الامريكيه
بانه قرار ويوم تاريخي واما وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي توني بلانكن الرئيس الروسي بشده
وقال ان الروسي قتلت الالاف من
الاوكرانيين اما عن التوقف عن القتال فقال
كلمه في الحقيقه توقفت عندها قال اذا
توقفت روسيا عن القتال تنتهي الحرب اما
اذا توقفت اوكرانيا عن القتال فهي فستنتهي
اوكرانيا
لكي تبقى محفوظه في اذهان الناس ونعود
اليك في سياق تغطياتنا طلال شكرا جزيلا
ولجلسه مجلس الامن لتغطيه يعني هذا اليوم
التاريخي عام على بدايه هذه الحرب الحرب
التي غيرت العالم شكرا جزيلا لكمراسل
العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد مراسل العربيه
حذيفه عادل من واشنطن مراسل العربيه حسين
[موسيقى]
رغم القلق الذي انتاب قاده اوكرانيا بعد
استقاله رئيس الحكومه البريطانيه السابق
باريس جونسون بل الاسبق صيف العام الماضي
الا ان شيئا لم يتغير في سياسه بريطانيا
تجاه الحرب وضروره دعم اوكرانيا رغم تعاقب
رئيسي حكومه بعد جونسون ولكن
وقعت كالصاعقه على الحرب الاوكرانيه
الروسيه ظننا بان اوكرانيا ستخسر حليفا
قويا وروسيا ستخسر عدوا شرسا
لكن شيئا لم يتغير الحرب ذكرت بريطانيا في
اوروبا وفعلت سياسه خارجيه متميزه عن
اوروبا بعد
ومخالفه لنهج برلين وباريس الحديد
تلعب دورها التقليدي مره اخرى عندما يكون
هناك انقسام وعندما يكون هناك استقطاب في
قناتنا دائما ما تكون المملكه المتحده
بقوتها كعضو دائم في مجلس الامن وواحده من
افضل الجيوش العسكريه في قارتنا لتقديم
تضحيه الاقتصاديه اللازمه لاظهار هذه
القياده
ولا صوت يعلو فوق صوت المعركه خلافات
الاحزاب البريطانيه وضعت جانبا والجميع
انتهج سياسه متشدده تجاه الكرملين
حزب المحافظين او العمال وجهان لعمله
واحده فمهما تغيرت الوجوه فيت او تحت قبه
البرلمان الدعم العسكري والانساني
لاوكرانيا لا يتغير
ان دعم المملكه المتحده للشعب الاوكراني
موحد وفي حال اجراء انتخاباتنا العام
المقبل وتغيير الحكومه فان موقف المملكه
المتحده بشان اوكرانيا سيضل على حاله
يهبط الجنيه الاسترليني ام يرتفع تسقط
حكومه او تنتخب جديده تختلف الاحزاب
المعارضه مع الحكومه او تهادن لا فرق
سياسه بريطانيا ثابته في هذه الحمله
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا روسيا تحارب
على القاره الاوروبيه ومهما كانت عباء
الحرب على الحياه اليوميه للبريطانيين
لندن قررت مواجهه موسكو في اوكرانيا مصطفى
زاروه العربيه لندن
ادلت وكيله وزاره الخارجيه للشؤون
السياسيه في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
فيكتوريا نولاند بجمله تصريحات لوكاله تاس
الروسيه قالت فيها ان الحرب في اوكرانيا
قد تتوقف غدا اذا ما امر الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين بذلك ولكنه لا يبدو انه
متجه نحو هذا الخيار واضافت انهم جاهزون
لاجراء محادثات بشان معاهده ستارت الجديده
في اقرب وقت اذا ابدت روسيا استعدادها
لذلك مؤكده ان استمرار الحرب يعني ان
واشنطن لن تتوقف عن امداد اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه العسكريه مشيره الى ان العلاقات
بين روسيا وامريكا قد تعود لطبيعتها حالما
ينتهي الصراع في اوكرانيا
نائب المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
اهلا بك معنا
ديثا على شاشه العربيه في هذا اليوم الذي
نغطي فيه مرور عام على هذه الحرب مع مرور
هذا العام الصين تدخل على الخط وتطرح خطه
بدات ترحب بها عده اطراف ما حقيقه الموقف
الامريكي النهائي من هذه الخطه
يجب ان اكون واضحين جدا حول نوايا الصين
هنا قبل عام الصين وروسيا وقعها بان
المشتركا وافقه عليه انه شراكه بلا حدود
بين الطرفين ومن ذلك الوقت والصين توفروا
الدعم الاقتصادي والانساني والمالي لروسيا
والان وردتنا معلومات ان الصين حتى تزودوا
روسيا بالدعم الفتاك
فعلينا ان نفكر بنوايا
الصين لم تناقش خطه السلام هذه حتى مع
الاوكرانيين
فيجبكم واضحين ايضا ان الصين اذا ما ردت
حقا ان تساعد في حل هذه المشكله فعلها
تستغل نفوذها على تقول له توقف عن فوضى
هذه الحرب لان اذا توقفت روسيا عن المعارك
فسته الحرب واذا ما توقفت اوكرانيا عن
القتال فسوف تنتهي اوكرانيا ولكن يعني
هناك تصريحات الان من الاوكراني فرضنسكي
واعتقد انه المعني الاساسي بكل ما يحصل في
بلاده يقول العمل مع الصين ضروري لحل
الصراع بل ويتحدث عن وجود افكار اذا كانت
جيده نناقشها لما لا بينما على الطرف
الاخر وفي الاخبار العاجله يقول بانه حتى
وقف النار سيعطي روسيا القدره على استعاده
موقعها وعلى اعاده تسليح نفسها وعلى تقويه
نفسها مجددا يعني حتى وقف النار غير ممكن
مليون اوكراني والاطفال اختطفوا واخذوا
الى روسيا ونجمت عن دمار البنى التحتيه
المدنيه واستهدافي المدنيين هذه هي
المشكله على الحقيقيه بين ايدينا وما يجب
ان تتوقف الولايات المتحده ستبقى الى جانب
اوكرانيا وحلفائنا لوقف هذه الحرب هل يعني
كل ما تفضلت به بانه واشنطن تنعى الخطه
الصينيه تائدها في مهدها
كلا هذا الاسم الكلام الصحيح بالتاكيد نحن
ننظر الى الخطه الصين وهذا ما قلناه من
قبل ولكن في الختام فان الصين لم تثبت
انها وسيط نزيهه في هذه العمليه فالصين
استمرت بتزويديه الدعم الاقتصادي او
الدبلوماسيلي روسيا وحتى امتنعوا عن
التصويت في الجمعيه العامه على الرغم 141
دوله اخرى قررت الوقوف الى جانب اوكرانيا
ودعم قراري يطالب بسلام داء معادل والصين
امتنعت وهذا
يبرز علامه استواي لكن يجب ان يكون واضحين
عن عزله وياسر روسيا حيث بدات تميل الى
دول مثل ايران وكوريا الشماليه من اجل
الدعم واي دوله ترفض في ادانه روسيا فشلت
باداره ايران ايضا ايران تستخدم نفس
الاساليب المستخدمه في الشرق الاوسط الان
في اوروبا ترسل
القواعد المدنيه وانتم تعرفون ذلك وهي
تساعد الرساله لفعل نفس الشيء في اوكرانيا
وهذا غير مقبول
هيثم بعد مقترحات الصين تؤكد على
سياده اوكرانيا على اراضيها
ويجب حفظ ذلك ولكن في المقابل تقول بضروره
عدم اجراء توسعه للتكتلات العسكريه
والمقصود هنا عدم انضمام اوكرانيا الى حلف
شمال الاطلسي النيتو ماذا تفهمون من يخطه
الصين بخصوص الحفاظ على السياده
الاوكرانيه وعلى اي مناطق تحديدا وهل يشمل
ذلك شبه جزيره القرم وهل يمكن ان يكون ذلك
مقابل عدم انضمام اوكرانيا نهائيا كتعهد
دوله الى حلف الشمالي الاطلسي
مفتوح من القرار السيادي لاي دوله هي التي
تحدد اراده ان تنضم او ان لا تنضم
غزوير بوتين غير الشارع الى اوكرانيا فقد
شهد زياده في وحده وقوته الناتو نتيجه
لتصرفات بوتين الان فنلندا والسويد تقدمتا
للعضويه ولكن المتحده تدعم بالكامل هذا
التوسع
فهو بشكل ما يعكسه فشل محاولات بوتين حاول
بوتين قبل عام من الان ان يكتحس اوكرانيا
عن الوجود
وكذلك حاول بث القسمه بين دول الناتو ولكن
بعد عام لا تزال قويه وحلف الناتو الان
اقوى من اي وقت سبق شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه
معنا لكيا من واشنطن تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
مستمره من العربيه ولكن بعد هذا الفاصل
القصير
[موسيقى]
عمليه روسيا العسكريه في اوكرانيا نقطه
البدايه بوتن يامر بارسال قوته واليات
ثقيله الى دومباس
الحادي والعشرين من فبراير 2022 بوتين
يعترف باستقلال دوناتسك ولوجانسك
الانفصاليتين
في الثاني والعشرين من فبراير بايدن يؤكد
بدايه غزو روسي لاوكرانيا
بعدها بيوم اوكرانيا تعلن حاله الطوارئ
على مستوى البلاد
في الرابع والعشرين من فبراير الساعه
الخامسه فجرا بتوقيت اوكرانيا بوتين يعلن
بدء عمليه عسكريه خاصه شرقي اوكرانيا بعد
دقائق سمع دوي انفجارات في كييف وخركيف
واوداسا ودومباس في الساعه السادسه 48
دقيقه صباحا مركبات روسيه عسكريه دخلت الى
اوكرانيا عبر سنغافكا وقبل الساعه السابعه
صباحا زيلنسكي يعلن الاحكام العرفيه في
اوكرانيا ويامر الجيش بالحاق اقصى الخسائر
بالغزات هكذا كانت البدايه والحرب مستمره
منذ عام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه التغطيه
المستمره من العربيه للذكرى الاولى للحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا تعتبر مدينه ايزيوم
واحده من اكثر المدن دمارا جراء ما حصل في
اوكرانيا فقد قتل اكثر من الف مداني خلال
سبعه اشهر سيطرت فيها القوات الروسيه على
المدينه وقتلت فيها المئات من المدنيين
موفد العربيه احمد بقاتو
تتواجد الان في واحده
من انهي هذه المقبره تقع في مدينه ايزوم
التابعه اداريه لمقاطعه خركيف والقريبه
للغايه من محيط الاشتراكات بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه هنا دفن اكثر
من 430 مدنيا قتلهم الجنود الروس كما تقول
المصادر العسكريه الاوكرانيه المدنيين
الذين التقيناهم في المدينه يقولون انهم
خائفون للغايه بل ومرتعبون من عوده الجنود
الروس مره اخرى خاصه بعدما نال المدينه من
دمار وتخريب وقتل لاكثر من 2000 شخص خلال
عام كامل من هذه الحرب
ايه يعني هتشوف انوي ان اخرج من البيت
وفجاه ظهرت احدى الطائرات الروسيه وقامت
باطلاق الرصاص عشوائيا على المدنيين في
الشارع فوقعت على الارض
وقوعي على الارض من الخوف انقذني هذا
الجسر الذي نقف عليه الان كان جسرا يربط
ما بين مدينه ايزوم وضواحيها فجرته القوات
الاوكرانيه لمنع وصول التعزيزاته القوات
الروسيه التي كانت تحتل هذه المدينه ولا
يبدو ان ترميما او بناء جديدا لهذا الجسر
عما قريب فاتخوف ما زال قائما من عوده
الروس مره اخرى لهذه المدينه مع قدوم فصل
الربيع وهذا مثال واضح لما مر على هذه
المدينه من اثر الحرب
كنا نعيش رعبا كاملا نظرا للقصف الروسي
المستمر وكنا لا نستطيع التحرك سوى القليل
لا استطيع ان اصدق ان الروس يريدون العوده
مره اخرى ماذا يريدون منا بعد ان دمروا
بلادنا
بصوره مستمره تدوي صافرات الانذار هنا في
سماء مدينه ايزوم بقربها من محيط
الاشتباكات الرعب والخوف يسيطر بصوره
مستمره على المواطنين هنا الذين يقولون ان
هذه الحرب التي دامت لعام كامل شردت
الكثير منهم ويعتمد اطفالهم ودمرت بيوتهم
هنا في هذا المبنى رفع زينسكي بنفسه لعلم
الاوكراني عليه بعد ان نجحت القوات
الاوكرانيه في تحرير هذه المدينه من سيطره
القوات الروسيه سيطره يتخوف المواطنون هنا
ان تفقدها قوات الاوكرانيه بعد عوده
متوقعه للجنود الروس نقله العربيه والحدث
احمد بجاتو مدينه ايزو
ينضم الينا الان من ابوظبي عبر زوم في
تاليفيدياني دبلوماسي الاوكراني ومن موسكو
المحلل السياسي افغيني اهلا بكما وابدا من
موسكو مع سيدافيني واسالك بناء على او
انطلاقا من الموقف الروسي الاخير الحالي
للتو صدر عن تشديد روسيا هو واضح طبعا قبل
ولكن بعد الخطه الصينيه وكل ما قيل فيها
اقصد هناك تشديد مجدد على الاعتراف بضم
اراضي اوكرانيه وفقا للخارجيه الروسيه
فيما اوكرانيا تقول انه اي خطه سلام لابد
ان تشمل انسحاب روسيا الى حدود عام 91
لا يبدو ان هناك نقطه انطلاق بين الطرفين
حتى الساعه
تحيه لك مره اخرى والاساده المشاهدين
والدي فيكم الكريم تبعد طبعا في غياب نقطه
انطلاق وهذا امر صحيح تماما ويعكس الواقع
واقع من الصعب التحدث عن قرب بدايه او
العوده الى المفوضات ولكن مع ذلك يبدو ان
مطالب كييف
بالعوده الى حدود 91 هي مطالب لا يمكن ان
تقبل به بها موسكو في اي حال من الاحوال
لان ذلك تشمل شبه جزيره القرم الخط الاحمر
بالنسبه لروسيا في اي مفاوضات وهي دائما
خارجه المعادله كما سبق الخطه الصينيه
الخطه الصينيه قالت سياده الدول الحفاظ
على سياده دول واستقلالها يعني الا اذا
كان البعض يريد ان يفسر ذلك على هواه وفقا
لحساباته
نعم هذا الصحيح ولكن بما اننا لا نعرف
تفاصيل الخطه الصينيه يمكننا ان نبني
فرضيه مفردها ان ربما مساله شبه الجزيره
للخرم ملف القرم بقي خارج يعني هذه
المعادله هو خارج ورقه عمل قدمتها الصين
الى روسيا علما بان بعض لمبات تفيد بان
بانه قبل هذه المبادره ورقه العمل الصينيه
سبق ذلك عديد من المجوهرات بين روسيا
والصين وهذا يعني برايي اما ان روسيا ربما
باركت طرح هذه الورقه ولكن لديها كما يبدو
تحفظات تتعلق بمساله ربما سياده اوكرانيا
علما بان روسيا تعتبر
جزءا لا يستهان به من هذه الاراضي اراضي
روسيه
قالت قبل قليل نتمم جهود الاصدقاء في
الصين لتسويه النزاع في اوكرانيا سلميا
دعني انتقل هنا لو تكرمت الى فيديانين
يبدو انه موقف زيلينسكي غير مغلق تماما
لمناقشه بعض الافكار الصينيه التي طرحت في
هذه الخطه ما حقيقه الموقف الاوكراني ما
الذي تقبله كييف والذي لا تقبله من هذه
الخطه
مساء الخير الكرام
الموقف الاوكراني واضح جدا اي مقترح
للسلام الصينيا كان يعني عربيا فضائيا يجب
ان يتماشى مع شرط البسيط انسحاب القوات
الروسيه من اوكرانيا
ووضعت رئيس اوكرانيا صيغه السلام وهدفها
الاساسي اخراج الروسيه من اراضينا ونحن
نقول هذا من جديد
نحن
نطلب انسحاب الفوري للقوات الروسيه من
ارضنا اذا ما انسحبت روسيا قواتها فنحن
سنفعل هذا ولكن انتم تدعون ذلك يعني حتى
انطلاقا من رفض وقف اطلاق النار كي لا
تعطوا فرصه للروس كما تقولون لاعاده تقويه
انفسهم
وقال انه اي خطه سلام تتضمن وقفا لاطلاق
النار فقط وبالتالي ترسيم حدود جديده
ومواصله احتلال الاراضي الاوكرانيه كما
سماها لا تستهدف السلام ولكن تجميد الحرب
وهزيمه اوكرانيه والمراحل المقبله من
الاباده الجماعيه على يد روسيا البعض يقول
انه انتم يعني تاتمرون باوامر الغرب وكل
ما يريد في استمرار هذه المعركه ولا
تراعون شؤونكم الوطنيه والقوميه ومصالحكم
الخاصه
لا نحن لا نريد استمرار هذه الحرب نحن
نريد تحرير ارضنا لان لا يمكن ان نسمح ان
تكون الاراضي الاوكرانيه تحت الاحتلال
الروسي وان يكون شعبنا يعني تحت احتلال
المعتدل الروسي ونحن نعتقد ان اي مفوضات
يعني يعني قبل الانسحاب الروسي من ارضنا
يعني هي اطفاء الشرعيه للاحتلال الروسي
وهذا يعني موقف يعني بسيط جدا حتى يعني
وقف اطلاق النار يعني لا يعطي لنا شيء
يعني وهو فقط يعني تجمد هذا النزاع
يقومني باتقاءه الشرعيه على الاحتلال هذا
يعني موقع
ساعود اليكم ولكن اذكر بما يقوله الان
ايضا بانه المبادر في ايه مبادره سلام يجب
ان يكون من الدوله المعنيه مباشره بالحرب
التي تجري فيها الحرب على اراضيها والمزيد
من التصريحات من البيت الابيض لمستشار
البيت الابيض للامن القومي عن مجموعه
السبع يتحدث عن انه التركيز في هذه
المجموعه حصل على ما يمكن عمله للمزيد من
المساعده لاوكرانيا لكي تنجح على ارض
المعركه
هذا بالنسبه الى البعض يقود الى المزيد من
التدخلات على الطرف الاخر على الطرف
الروسي من الصين وغير ذلك والحديث اليوم
كما نقلت عن اعتزام الصين تصنيع مسيرات
هجوميه لتستخدمها روسيا في اوكرانيا
والخارجيه الامريكيه اكدت لنا هذا الكلام
قبل قليل ما رايك
باختصار شديده ما دامت الصين لم تؤكد يعني
مثل هذه الانبا بل تنفي هذا نفيا قاطعا
لان هذا لو قررت الصين تزويد روسيا
بالمزيد من الاسلحه بالمسيرات وتصنيعها
خصيصا لروسيا او باي نوع اخر من السلاح
لما طرحت مثل هذه المبادره لان هناك تضارب
واضح يعني انت انت تطرح مبادره سلام بيد
اخر انت تعمل وتساعد في استمرار هذه
العمليه على فكره وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
لم ترد بشكل مباشر على سؤال ولكن عقاله
انه الولايات المتحده هي المصدر الرئيسي
للتسلح في ساحه المعركه للانصاف فقط كلمه
اخيره استاذ بديانيين ردك على ما تفضل به
سيد
طبعا طبعا نحن غيرنا موقفنا لان فهمنا ان
روسيا يعني نفسها لم تغير خطتها
الاستعماريه لتدمير واحتلال اوكرانيا في
كل مره لما تدعوا روسيا يعني بالنفاق يعني
وبكل سخريه للمفاوضات وفي نفس الوقت يعني
المدن الاوكرانيه المسالمه وتقبل المدنيين
وتحول المواصله التقدم نحن نشوف كيف يواصل
قواته والاسلحه والذخائر حتى الخارج
ولماذا لماذا هل تستعيد موسكو للسلام ام
لقتل المزيد من الاوكرانيين نحن نعتقد ان
النقطه الثانيه قتل المدنيين صحيحه وهذا
ما يؤكد يعني بوضوح المسؤولين الروس عندما
يلوحون يعني باحتلال اوكرانيا حتى الحدود
مع بولندا يعني كنا نامل انه بعد عام على
البدايه هذه العمليه الخاصه كما تسميها
روسيا وغزو كما تسميه اوكرانيا ان يكون
الحوار فيه نقاط مشتركه اكثر ولكن هذا هو
الواقع ونقلناه بناء على هذا الحوار
بينكما استاذ فيتالي فيديانيين
الدبلوماسيه الاوكرانيين من ابو ظبي عبر
زوم ومن موسكو المحلل سياسي شكرا جزيلا
لكما تحياتي
[موسيقى]
لعبت السعوديه دورا مركزيا في الافراج عن
حوالي عشره اسرى حرب تم اعتقالهم من قبل
القوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا ومنهم الجندي
الامريكي السابق الذي خدم في العراق وفي
افغانستان اليكسا دروكي العربيه التقط
عائله الاسير المحرر في ولايه الاباما
الجنوبيه ليشارك تفاصيل اسره واطلاق سراحه
كذلك بواسطه من ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان
تحاول عبثا ان تمنع دموع ام ممتنه بعوده
ابنها من الاسر
في بيتهم في تسكلوسه في ولايه الاباما
ذهبنا لنسمع من هذه العائله كيف نجحت
الوساطه السعوديه بتعليمات من ولي العهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان باطلاق سراح اليكس
دروكي من سجن روسي بعد اعتقاله لمده اربعه
اشهر اليكس تطوع للقتال في صفوف القوات
الاوكرانيه الى ان وقع بالاسر من قبل
الجنود الروس الذين قاموا بتعذيبه وترك
مصيره معلقا بين الحياه والموت
ان اتمكن من تجاوز هذا دون ان ابكي انا
ممتنه جدا لتدخل ولي العهد ومساعدته اعتقد
حقا ان اليكس لن يكون هنا اليوم لو لم يكن
ولي العهد على استعداد تام للمساعده ساكون
مديونه دائما للسعوديه وللشعب ولولي العهد
على وجه الخصوص اليكس الذي يتعافى بعد
الاسر لا يزال يعاني مختلف في الاعصاب
ومتاعب صحيه ويخضع لمراقبه طبيه يحاول ان
ينحت بالخشب ليمرن اصابعه المعطوبه لكنه
يعتبر نفسه محظوظا كونه واحدا من عشر اسرى
حرب تم اطلاق سراحهم بواسطه سعوديه
انتظرنا في المطار ثم اخذونا اخيرا الى
الترام وراينا هناك على المدرسه طائره
سعوديه كبيره وقلنا حسنا هذا ليس حقيقيا
لن يتم وضعنا فيها ثم كنت اتساءل ما هي
تلك الطائره هناك ثم وضعنا فيها وبدا
الموظفون السعوديون في الواقع يتحدثون
الينا ويشرحون ما يجري ويقولون اننا في
امان وانه سوف يطلق صراحنا وانهم سوف
يعتنون بنا لم يكن الامر حقيقيا حتى بطن
في الرياض
سباق مع الزمن من اسره اليكس في محاوله
لاطلاق سراحه ترويها خالته ديانه حيث قامت
بالاتصال مع شلبي ومع وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه لكن الافراج عنه جاء من جهه لم
تتوقعها
لم نكن متاكدين بالضبط من الجهه البسيطه
المساعده ثم عندما علمنا انها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه كان الامر منطقيا بالطبع
لكننا لا زلنا لا نعرف بالضبط كيف حدث ذلك
لا نعرف كيف بدا الامر وكم من الوقت
استغرقت العمليه لاننا كنا نوعا ما في
الظلام اخبرتنا وزاره الخارجيه ان امورا
كانت تحدث لكنهم لم يتمكنوا من اخبارنا
بتفاصيلها لا شيء يضاهي عوده ابن سالما من
حرب بعيده لكن لدى اسره الدروكي امنيه
وحيده وهي شكر السعوديه على منح ابنها
فرصه ثانيه في الحياه ناديه البلبيسي
العربيه تسكلوسه من ولايه الاباما
برعايه سعوديه عمليه تبادل اسرى بين روسيا
واوكرانيا
وساطه ولي العهد السعودي تنجح بالافراج عن
عشره اسرار
[موسيقى]
الاسرى المحررون من خمس جنسيات المغرب
وامريكا وبريطانيا والسويد وكرواتيا
السعوديه نقلت الاسرى من روسيا الى الرياض
الحادي والعشرون من سبتمبر 2022 وصول
الاسرى العشره الى السعوديه
تاييد دولي واسع لوساطه ولي العهد السعودي
نشكر شركاء السعوديين على المساعده في
قياده هذه المبادره الانسانيه وتسهيل عوده
عشره اجانب بما فيهم مواطناني امريكيان
استقبلهما فريق سفاراتنا في الرياض
كانت مبادره جيده نظرا للعلاقات التي
يمتلكها ولي العهد مع روسيا كانت فرص
النجاح مرتفعه وانا ممتن جدا له على هذه
النتيجه الرائعه
طبعا الازمه في اوكرانيا منذ بدايتها وعرض
وساطتها على الطرفان على
روسيا واوكرانيا لايجاد حلها ومنذ ذلك
الحين وهو يتابع التطورات وعند عما علم عن
موضوع هذول الاسرى وصعوبه
خروجهم وتعقيدات لانها كانت عمليه معقده
حقيقه منذ ابريل بدا في الحوار مع الاطراف
وعمل عليها
استمرار خلال الفتره الماضيه الى حين تمت
الصفقه وخرجوا الان في طريقهم الى اهلي
فكان هذا نتيجه حقيقه لاستمرار سمو في
متابعه الامر وحواره المباشر مع جميع
الاطراف نعود بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تغطتنا مستمره للذكرى
الاولى للحرب في اوكرانيا ونذهب الى
واشنطن الان التي اعلنت عن رزمه عقوبات
جديده على موسكو بعد عام على بدء الحرب
العقوبات الجديده تستهدف ايضا افرادا
وشركات في دول اوروبيه وتحديدا في سويسرا
وقالت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه ان واشنطن
استهدفت شركات وافرادا روسا في قطاعات
المعادن والمناجم والمعدات العسكريه
واشباه الموصلات
معنا من واشنطن الخبير في الشؤون
الامريكيه وليد فارس اهلا بك معنا استاذ
وليد مره جديده في هذه التغطيه واريد ان
اقف معك على حقيقه الموقف الامريكي عام
بعد بدء هذه الحرب اين تقف واشنطن الان
يعني معروف موقفها مع اوكرانيا ولكن من
خطط السلام اما مثلا الصينيه اليوم
الموقف في واشنطن تحت هذه الاداره وخاصه
الان مع هذا الكونجرس قد تبدل منذ العام
الماضي ولو قليلا ولكن قد يدخل في مرحله
جديده الموقف العام لاداره بايدن عندما
بدا هذا هذه المواجهه كان ان يدعم
اوكرانيا وقواتها ورئيسها كي لا تسقط
الدوله الاوكرانيه هذا هو الهدف الاساسي
لانه كانت تسمع عن اصوات تاتي من من تقول
يجب ازاله الدوله الاوكرانيه اذا هذا كان
الهدف الاساسي مما يفسر كل هذه المليارات
التي ارسلت من اجل المحافظه على الدوله لم
تتكلم عن اي حدود هذا لم يكن واضحا بينما
الحكومه الاوكرانيه كانت تقول نريد ان
نحرر كل الاراضي حتى اخر شبر الولايات تحت
الامريكيه كانت تقول سوف نحمي اوكرانيا
وهذه الدوله فيها انما الامر بدا يتبدل
قليلا عندما شعرت هذه الاداره بان الروس
والقياده الكرملين متمسكين بالمناطق التي
اعتبرت حمراء يعني المناطق في الجنوب وفي
القرن وحول بحر ازوف وقالت وقتها القياده
الروسيه سوف نستعمل كل الاسلحه مما يعني
ربما النووي التكتيكي هذا بدل في الموقف
الامريكي فبالتالي اداره بيض تصعد على كل
الجبهات الا جبهه واحده وهي الاصطدام مع
الروس ونحن موجودين الان في هذه المرحله
حيث تدعم الدوله الاوكرانيه من ناحيه
ولكنها لا تريد الذهاب الى الاصطدام يعني
امريكا يمكن يمكن نقول انه تذهب الى
الاقرار بانه هذه المناطق التي قالت روسيا
انا ضميتها بانه اصبحت جزءا لا يتجزا منها
فعلا ويكون كل الكلام في اي خطه مقبله على
كل ما تبقى من اوكرانيا
اقل من ذلك بشويه يعني الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لن تعترف قانونيا بالاحتلال
الروسي لهذه المناطق لانه في اليه معينه
للانتقال الاراضي وهو وقف اطلاق نار تفاهم
بين الدولتين تفاوض وصول الى ما يسمى
وبعدها اذا توافق الاثنان على تبديل هذه
الاراضي عندها تقبل الاداره ولكن هي تريد
ولا تعترف تغض النظر تغض الطرف ولا تعترف
صحيح هذا الكلام صحيح هذا فيما يتعلق
بالارض ولكن هناك امور اخرى في الخطط
الصينيه متعلقه
بوضعيه اوكرانيا من حيثيه الانضمام وهذه
كانت عقده اساسيه بدات الحرب على اساسها
انضمام اوكرانيا الى حلف شمالي الاطلسي
وتطالب الصين بوقف التوسيع التكتلات
العسكريه هل يمكن ان تتخلى واشنطن ايضا عن
ذلك
الموقف الصيني الصيني عمليا هو منسق مع
الموقف الروسي يعني ما لا تريد روسي ان
تقوله لان هي على الجبهه وبالتالي عليها
ان ترد اذا حصل امر من هذا النوع تقوله
الصين موقع نفسها الصين ان هي بين الطرفين
بينما عمليا هي خليفه لروسيا في موضوع
الاتحاد الاوروبي والنيتو حتى هذه الاداره
وبرسل هم متانين بهذا الموضوع يعني اول
شيء يريدون وصول الوقف اطلاق نار بعده الى
مفاوضات وبعدها اسف جدا شكرا جزيلا على
مشاركتك معنا لنا وقفات اخرى التغطيه
مستمره مع صهيب شرايب بعد قليل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]